you
you
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar where to go from here next
generation clinical mass spectrometry
presented by dr. Victoria Jeong a vice
chair in the department of pathology and
laboratory medicine at University of
Rochester Medical Center i'm susie
valdez and I'll be your moderator for
this educational webinar
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab reach the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual event and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
and made possible by an open educational
grant from agilent technologies agilent
technologies has had no input in a
selection of speakers content or mode of
presentation before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type that question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also notice
that you're viewing the presentation in
a slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon located at
the lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use that Q&A button and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom
left-hand corner
to obtain your credit without further
adieu I'd now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. victoria zhang victoria jon
is a vice chair of the department of
pathology and Laboratory Medicine at the
University of Rochester Medical Center
she is the medical director of the
ambulatory services director of clinical
mass spectrometry and toxicology
laboratory the Associate Director of the
clinical chemistry laboratory at Strong
Memorial Hospital and the associate
professor of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine dr. jeong is an international
leading
for in clinical applications of mass
spectrometry for clinical and research
interests are in the clinical mass
spectrometry translational research
using omics technology test utilization
particularly through the laboratory
formulary model and laboratory
management and leadership development
she has published over 50 peer-reviewed
articles and book chapters over 70
national and international presentations
and numerous media reports and
interviews dr. John has been an
organizing committees for nearly 20
regional or national conferences with
similar number of international and
national symposia workshops and short
courses she's on several editorial
boards in the field of clinical
chemistry and laboratory medicine dr.
John has devoted her efforts into mass
spectometry education for the clinical
community in the past few years she is
the founding and current chair of the
AAC Steve mass spectometry and
separation sciences at M s cube division
the faculty chair of to online
certificate programs for mass
spectrometry and spearheaded the
national mass spectrometry workshops
during the AACC and the AAC cm s cube
annual conferences she is a faculty
chair of the AACC global lab quality
initiative in asian-pacific working
group to lead the efforts to enhance
quality and practice of clinical
chemistry in this region dr. John was
also the president of north american
chinese clinical chemist association the
Past Chair of a ACC upstate New York
local section dr. John completed her
clinical chemistry fellowship training
at Harvard Medical School after
obtaining her PhD in biochemistry and
bioinformatics at the University of
Minnesota
she is certified as a diplomat of the
American Board of clinical chemistry
please join me in welcoming dr. victoria
jeong i will now turn the presentation
over to her welcome dr. alright well
thank you Susie so this is very nice and
warm introduction and a good morning
everybody or good afternoon people on
the East Coast
it's a great pleasure to be here to
present this year some beyond the area
that I'm passionate about with the
audience and thanks also for lab roots
to organize and the planning for this
session great so we will talk about
today is where to go from here
next-generation clinical mass
spectrometry alright
see so the presentation would give as a
title says more of a forty thousand foot
view of what's going on with a current
field of clinical mass spec and then
where to go from here this outline
listed a three items that I will cover
throughout this presentation first is a
general review of LC mass spec
applications so that get everybody on
the same page as the main topic and the
area of interest to is to discuss the
challenges in future implementation of
LC mass spec in clinical labs with that
LLC challenges create opportunities so
we're talk about not you know future
more of a new future applications of
electrochromic ography mass spec which
also coined by the ACCC and the MS cube
divisions call next-generation clinical
mass spectrometry is where we're talking
about from the current generation to the
next generation all right this slide
shows the clinical mass spec has been a
fast-growing field this is the number of
a publications that I searched through
PubMed at you on September 15th which is
about a month ago to check face 1991 to
current how many publications has the
number of related using clinical mass
spectrometry they were basket in every
five years and I see I get my pointer
here alright so this is basically from
this is first five years and I go up
1991 to 2016
so for 2016 I can see if this is the
projection we will have about this many
publications so we can really see a
overall a very high projection from
earlier years 20 years ago to now if we
think about even the past Tate of five
years from 2011 to 2015 that's about
over 10,000 publications so average
about 2000 per year that means it's
about 3 to 4 publications per day
related to clinical mass spec this is a
really a fast-growing field that we have
a lot of people dedicate to their you
know career and passion into this field
they also means that we have a lot of
exciting developments in this area so as
they're being said I think there's a lot
of things that we can and need to think
about for the future of clinical mass
spec all right
actually before we go further on it to
bring us back a little bit although
we're talking about mass spec now is a
very very hot field as your mass spec
itself already has more than a hundred
years history this shows a general
timeline of the mass spec development
back into 1899 JD Thomas the first
person who created the first mass spec
he also won 9006 Nobel Prize for his
innovation then we also have different
people across the time and devoted their
career for the development of mass spec
coming from this to this way 1950 that
women talk about quote for this is the
area that's got developed and then also
1984-85 this area that's when
electrospray ionization and ahmadi tov
Mahdi was introduced and dr. Johnson and
at the mr. Tanaka share the the 2002
Nobel Prize for their innovations so
there's a lotta SSE Nobel Prize involved
with the development of mass bed
it has been a great area that attracted
a lot of talent the clinical mass spec
actually have not really started until
the 1950s offshore a lot more in the
next few slides
so the overall is that we really had a
long and rich history of mass spec and
now we're just pushing them to the new
area called clinical Diagnostics and
from the laboratory perspective or the
instrument perspective this is what it
looked like before as we can see that
this is the original mass spec and I'll
list a few there's no preference of any
vendor or manufacturer this is just a
different model to that at search on
line with the new most popular
manufacturer names now they're how they
look like we can see it's really night
and day the functions are still there
they get also becomes much more powerful
and provide much more applications in
the clinical side s so powerful of mass
spec then we'll see why are we actually
using that back this is just to get
everybody on the same page as you know
we move forward you probably already
heard this from previous or other
presentations through the theory just to
summarize here there's a few elements of
mass spec that attracts people to bring
them to the clinical lab first one is
the high specificity the high
specificity comes from a few factors one
is fair to the HPLC retention time also
we have a molecular weight we also have
the monomer multiple reaction monitor
mechanism that enhances the specificity
of the identification for one of the
examples drug confirmation which in you
know as you cannot differentiate the
similar compounds but mass spec can do
that the second reason is a high
sensitivity I also see it's not always
the case is not universal but it is true
for some analytes which applied for
endocrine testing for insulin
testosterone that's utilized this high
sensitivity complete have a lower toot
excellent
the differential for instance female
versus male or particular have more
accurate measurement for low
testosterone concentrations and the
third part is a probably most discussed
which is the quick response to companies
what does that mean then is that
different from amino acid which requires
a development and selection and
perfection above the antibodies and also
through mostly the Atlanta FDA approval
process and is for for now we don't know
what's going to happen yet for the
future but mass spec provided a much
flexible in-house development process or
we call that laboratory development test
with what we need in the lab we can
develop the a3 according to a very
stringent clinical guidelines I mean
including state and federal guidelines
and development as is he how to support
and provide the needs that we need from
the clinical side some examples include
the designer drugs right those are
changes every day we're chasing the
tails those mesfet provided a great
opportunity for those another example
the immunosuppressant before we have a
new nazi those are mesfet waiting
portable another factor is the lower
operating cost and wanted to answer that
the operating site because we all know
it's pretty expensive lee to get a mass
spec but after you get it actually the
operating cost the day-to-day cost is a
relatively low as the regions are
expensive so this is the few reasons
that we use mass spec for clinical
assays all right so now the next
question is what asses have will be
using for clinical laboratories
currently I just give a few examples
here has a few this is a few very big
categories there's more applications
than this but those are the majority and
the major applications right now of mass
spec in clinical lab here as the title
says mass spec really not just a tool is
actually enhanced as a clinical
this and some of them that other
technologies can all provide but mass
spec has provided a unique niche to
really help the healthcare and the
patient care the first is the newborn
screening this is one of the early
applications of mass spec in clinical
lab although now we're talking a lot
about liquid chromatography the mass bed
here is started with a GC and there's so
many people using that so as I already
say technology we use their advantages
and the limited their weaknesses and
either GC and LC which air will work the
best for you it is the tool that you can
and need to choose so newborn screening
is one of the tools early stage used in
GC mass spec and now sometimes LC and
then there another point is a clinical
and forensic toxicology which involve
team and management drug of abuse and
also including forensic toxicology it
required different regulations but the
methodologies are very similar so that's
another major major area that has been
used by mass spec the third point is a
therapeutic drug monitoring that's also
an area that most people familiar with
for instance with the immunosuppressant
drugs and chemo therapy drugs or even
other antifungal drugs or others those
are all we can use mass spec to monitor
the drug dose and follow up with
treatment another area that we're all
pretty familiar with for mass spec is an
endocrinology but M&D is one of the
examples testosterone fire or hormones
that have be used in mass spec all right
there's also emerging applications
those include microbiology and I see
protein peptides
I call them emerging after microbiology
area now it's pretty well adapted I
really at this a fascinating field that
to see the Micra by the adoption mass
spec he microbiology has really changed
the hundred years of practicing
microbiology overnight by mass spec
and created significant a contribution
to health care by reducing turnaround
time so it's really fascinating
another area of more current chemistry's
pepper than proteins economy more than a
few applications here and there and also
we have a lot of continued interest in
this area to develop even more and I
have a box called like many other
applications as we see at the earliest
slide well you know or to over 2,000
publications every year which is every
time we turn around there's more
applications so it really has been a
very very exciting field so now as we
see we have current applications but
there's people asking how do we do more
in aspect what's really stopping us from
doing more so I wanted to bring this
back for people to think about the
challenges to brain mass spec assets to
clinical practices it's not Universal
many people want to do it but not
necessary easy or here are a few things
that the gaps that we can identify one
is the high cost for instrument it
typically is capped or equivalent
requires the service contract requires
infrastructure and to get them together
that's a few hundred thousand dollars
right for one se for one instrument it's
not cheap
another is the limit choices of
personnel so we need operating staff
when you're troubleshooting step we need
actually people to develop those assets
as they are left or develop a test and
we have to do that our in-house so those
are personnel are not readily available
so this is the second limitation three
is the complex workflow it requires a
lot of menu process and it's not
automated and requires special training
for the staff and for the laboratory to
accommodate to that the third part is
regulatory considerations as a
laboratory developed tests as we know
there's a lot of discussion from FDA
what's going to happen how we go about
it and even with the same as it is the
area that has been heavily debated we
you still kind of see where the
executive ruction what's going on
on the other hand I think people are
also we know that there's existing
regulations on top of that we have to
follow so that's the area of kind of
unknown so if I use this diagram to to
summarize what's going on with a lab use
you know this is basically my classic mo
diagram and how to bring mass spec now
into the patient site of C we'll have
one dollar to our people not only one of
them we need a lot of them so those are
real challenges that facing us that for
the adoption of this fascinating
platform this is what most people I
think the you can't we can pick on those
few items actually we also did an
interesting survey through the MS cube
division on mass spectrometry and
separate sizes division a couple years
ago to really also assess from the you
know the other members and the community
how do we general feel about it put some
you know we're all scientists we want to
put some numbers do scientific approach
to to see what you know what the
challenge we have so we asked the
question is whether areas that smack of
development here which means we call
them the current status as low but on
the other hand we also ask what the
question for needs more attention or put
a higher priority and we asked
manufacturers academic and
representative and also regularly bodies
the result is on the right it's based on
the low current status and plus the high
priority so this is basically the the
rank we have automation come to first
automation come to further than needs
the current status is low and also
people think that that think and believe
that they should to get a higher
priority so that's why the automation
ranked the top so the same way that we
rank to informaton
that education treaty is on the third
reimbursement it force commercial
applications this really mainly
referring to the commercial kids it's
available for the lab and disruptive
technologies and they instrument
sensitivity resolution the third part is
the precision medicine I want to imagine
precision medicine is one people you
feel like that the status is also low
but also there takes a lot more effort
to get it off ground so that's actually
it's very important in areas that it
just takes longer that's why it runs a
little bit low on the spot so I wanted
to point out three area automation
education disruptive technology as those
are the things that I will touch more in
this presentation
all right to put them in a different way
this is what I think about when we talk
about now we have it two challenges that
we wanted to talk about the
opportunities or we see or if we were to
talk about the next-generation clinical
mass spec what other areas that we
wanted to think about as you can see
this is actually relatively busy slides
a lot of areas that needs attention and
can be further developed so just to go
through briefly some of the elements one
is called se development as from as a
matrix we're moving from qualitative to
quantitative assays instrument asides
we're moving from big to small which is
the miniaturization of mass spec how
even think about how pointing here in a
you know setting so that people can
readily available a user that from
ammolite abundance perspective we wanted
them for high abundant low abundance
analyte from the instrument resolution
we wanted them to have a higher
resolution and readily available for
instruments and then from the clinical
field we're talking from CP to AP which
is from the expanding just from
chemistry every spanning from even
clinical pathology
anatomical pathology from the molecular
size perspective we're working out from
small molecule to large molecules and
the workflow automation so those are all
the pillars that when we talk about the
next generation Qualcomm aspect that
need attention and deserves attention
for us to to study more all right here
let's see and the bottom here is also
the training education for med tech
residents sellin and pathology becomes a
very very important area which I put
them at the bottom because they are the
foundation of all those areas to even
move forward for the rest of the
presentation I'll just focus on extra
those three things and also education to
focus on those areas like what if we
have been doing what is the challenge
move forward and just give you know
people from I think elements to think
about to where we go from here all right
from the first one clinical field from
CP moving to the AP anatomic pathology
side all this can seem like teach you
imaging I'll use it actually just a
couple of slides talk about a very high
level as you know all basically on the
40,000 foot view of this area or people
call them body imaging mass spec this is
the center the current of practice in
anatomical pathology people help you the
size they get here and a read and a
microscope either alone or in a group
this is actually the resident the
picture of our residents sitting
together discuss what's going to happen
or I find another interesting picture I
just have I thought that's really cool
to see how people get a consensus to
really look at using everybody to
expertise to find the perfect the right
diagnosis for patients it has been going
on for a long time really provided a
great values for clinical practice so
the question is that how can we use mass
spec to support the development
the applications of in this field so as
we know this is the area basically is a
multi imaging mass spec the goal or the
hope it reports the microscopes with a
model of mass spectrometry that we're
showing here so I'll just as a very
high-level to discuss the process it's a
very very interesting field it has a lot
of experts working in this area this
slide just to show a general workflow of
imaging aspect just to see the
feasibility of that and you know people
have been doing that and we are working
on it I think this is a very very like a
feasible area for the future to for us
to give more thoughts
so on the top that is you know the
Molotov process right we have the
ionization process we have the top two
separate ions and then get the spectra
at the end so with a tissue at the front
and we can also sampling at each
different spots on each teacher and also
with the teacher slides we can slice
them in a different way so as a result
we could get thousands or hundreds of
the spectra that's showing underneath
here all right so this is a let me get
my pointer here so that we know what
we're talking about this so this is one
of the representative Spectras from
Maudie we know Maudie as we typically
won't charge it doesn't have a bigger
molecular weight arraigned to go to here
at 20,000 so each spot of that can come
with a spectra like this so one teachers
light can come with like hundreds of
thousands of that and then this can be
mapped out of each component a molecular
weight across 3d dimensional to see
where they are located on the tissue so
that's how we get the now we're talking
about let's see here all right so we're
talking about those
right so this is the area of the average
spectrum of that molecular weight across
hundreds or thousands of slides to put
them together so this so that we can
view the compounds our analyte in this
fashion and then we can identify the
boundaries or a different
differentiation normal modern processing
malignant tissues so this is the general
idea the samples we people have been
using either fresh frozen or form fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues FFPE tissues
the analytes with the power of mass spec
we can analyze proteins peptides lipids
drugs and metabolites or even
xenobiotics
through mass spec also there are why we
are excited with a lot of developments
there are certain challenges of this
just to summarize at a very very high
level here one is the detection limit
you know how long can we go with a
molecular weight or what's the area of
the other on the tissue and also n
suppression when we deal with like a
hold tissues there comes with iron
suppression how do we and other
interference another example integrity
when you know importance it like a fresh
frozen versus FFT each issues will come
with a different level of example and
integrity how do we handle those issues
those are all their activity study the
areas and also imaging resolution it's
like two microns enough or all of the
size of laser so that we can create
enough spectrums for us to analyze and
also the speed of the imaging although
mass spec is a pretty fast but we're
really talking about you know sampling
the whole t-shirt slide and also with
multiple that it takes a lot of time but
all the after the image resolution speed
of imaging has been increased
significantly in the past few years but
there's still room for improvement
another area the sample heterogeneity is
just because you know the cancer one
cancer is different from another how do
we really have enough sample pool to see
to cut to to develop the the patterns
for us to you to differentiated
different stages so that is also a
critical component and by the end of the
day there's another area which is
informatics how do we handle all this
data all of those are interesting
questions important questions to ask
also related to image and aspect but the
field has been developed a lot is very
exciting just to see that mass spec can
go from just you know chemistry from
chemistry team to microbiology basically
to Chronicle pathology na now to
anatomical pathology so this is one area
that has been actively studied alright
so this is a image miss Packard or
tissue imaging another area I wanted to
discuss is the molecular molecule size
so see traditionally mass spec has been
using on the clinical side is these
small molecules and now what we wanted
to do is move to the large molecules we
talked about large mainly it's protein
peptides or lipids so this is the area
coming from you know urine clinical all
friends of toxicology as we discussed
previously another peptide and proteins
so this area already have a lot of study
I think people know more of this
actually know do a lot of information in
this area and personally actually I
started with the proteomics now you know
working into small large now coming back
is also how that you really a special
place in my heart for in this area so I
wanted to spend you know the next few
slides to talk about this development
and the area and the challenges will
move from small molecule to peptides all
right so this slice
jaren talked about the workflow for
people also referring that at target and
mass spec in a clear certified
laboratory when we talk about from
discussing from small molecules to the
peptides
their typical three components
that I would like to separate that one
is the sample preparation to compare
what is similar to other differences and
then the loc method separation and mass
spec analysis so in this area actually
the mass spec analysis is essentially
the same they all use triple quad and
the separation is also similar that's
typically used reverse phase right or
most commonly used columns a really most
challenges small molecule versus protein
peptides is the sample prep all right so
what does fan mean what does that
include so this is slide shows a sample
prep workflow in a clinical lab what
we're used to is working small molecules
this is a showing is the small molecule
working flow do you see the slides here
we have I have two colors here one is
the I said the brownish color this is a
protein and lipid there's also a bright
more of orange color we're shooting on
your this is means the small
representing small molecules in a
patient sample what we normally do in
when we work with the small molecules is
we use a protein crash meaning get rid
of proteins
what we want is what's left on top which
is a small molecule to study and as we
purify that and concentrate that we put
them into mass spec this is the general
workflow if we're interested in protein
C and move to the next part alright
great so we actually wanted to capture
those proteins so that we want the large
molecules to study and we wanted to
discard those small molecules so that to
achieve that it requires different tools
and technologies here listed a few that
typically used for the captain
protein process one is immuno affinity
enrichment and we also need proteins
denature ization and protein digestion
and purification at the end we also need
another final cleanup step excuse me
alright so after the final cleanup step
that's when we send the samples to mass
spec for analysis or in a different way
to view this over a workflow for
proteins it will look like this
some of the steps could be sooner or
later a different stage but overall this
is just one of the workflows
individually might be different so we'll
just use this as an example to show this
is this is pretty I think something
generic the one is the protein
enrichment there's so many proteins
different kinds of proteins in se serum
or plasma so if we were to study one
specific protein we wanted to in which
or extract them the technology we
typically use is affinity chromatography
or multi-step letter chromatography or I
inks change size exclusion exclusion and
etc those method we typically use for
protein enrichment and then we have to
use the nature evasion the natural stage
will be difficult for the next step
which is called digestion - wanted them
to do nature and separate the disulfide
bond so there the completely relaxed in
the solution after that we wanted to do
here digest the proteins into peptides
in the clinical lab we don't really
measure protein directly we do have a
conversation talking about top-down
approach but generally speaking so far
we need to we measure it on the peptide
level so there either chemical Allies
ematic digestion one of the most
commonly used is the trypsin digestion
then after that we will enrich the pet
and then to separate the peptides from
all other of the peptide of interest in
from other peptides either use in unison
in the columns or these or other
technologies then after that at this
point as we know Mexico back is a pretty
tricky and most compounds going through
this process are not method compatible
with the mass spec we had to do a
cleanup like remove sauce detergents
polymers solvents Regency cetera so that
they will be mass spec ready so it is a
very different workflow than what we
normally do or we're used to in the lab
so those are a different way to just to
list a few things in a different way to
talk about the workflow is you reduce
your agents all proteins are jesting use
a couple examples so people have to
learn this technology to actually apply
to the mass spec even for people who are
familiar with the proteins which drove
them is a protein discovery or
proteomics it's not actually still with
a clinical as you there's still a lot
some gap and people need to narrow that
gap to put a se that that's a clinical
greed so those are actually different
layers of challenges
here's we talked about that Jasmine does
this show what really what what does
that really mean so the deaths and
conditions can have a big impact on
energy performance
this is adopted from reconstructed from
paper dr. hope lingo publish on clinical
chemistry talk about toggle open a
digestion the here is a list are six six
peptides or this area and then based on
three digestion conditions be a ranked
acted by the based on the first adjacent
area condition those are three
specifically one two three on the Left
elicited and not really on the
discussing point just know there are
three different way to digest this
sample but what's important here
to see the diversity and variability of
the signal from different peptides based
on different digestions
for instance new further let's see the
first one based on the digestion
condition number one it has pretty high
signal it's also high in the digestion
condition - how they're producing
peptide and when you're really looking
at star here it has a very low signal
general speaking the digesting condition
number three provided a lower signal
that's not what we want
on the other hand let's see here let's
see the fourth peptide let me get my
pointer this is not the highest the
peptide generate you know the general
generate one of the highest the signals
but the Jessie actually number two was
pretty good right someone our condition
as this one there's also lower for a
model six peptide based on digestion
condition one but it this is a pretty
high based on that Jess and condition
two so the take-home message here is
that different that Jasmin work
generated different signals and a lot of
variability and the choice of that will
be very important and also determines
which peptide are we going to use this
generate a lot of challenges for will we
move to the peptide or protein room from
small molecules and this figure actress
shows another layer of a complexity of
studying proteins we study small
molecules that's practically that's one
compound and based on a fragmentation of
the compound mrm or as I am to determine
the the molecule but when we talk about
proteins that there are different areas
that we come back to consider that's
elicited on the left side one is there's
more peptide to choose there's also
sample preparation conditions that we
need to think about also difficult to
find the you
big peptide to choose from also
complicated fragment patterns so here on
the right side if we can see this is a
peptide that in choosing presario oval
and for the measurement of the one
peptide for the entire protein so this
peptide is better to be unique and
provided enough signals so this is just
think about how many peptides and
generated through all this the whole
protein but even finding this one
becomes challenging but even for this
one peptide also have much more
complicated fragment pattern as we
showing here through which fragment
peptide when we need to use and a
monitor that becomes another question so
overall as this indicated is not that
it's too easy to identify you know the
unique items for protein Fe so there's a
list a few things that we talked about
before like also the challenge for
protein as a low abundance post
translational modification where it
should not have a protein heterogeneity
those are all other challenges for
protein asses alright so this is the
where we move from small to big
molecules another I wanted to touch base
a little bit is the workflow how do we
move from menu and to automation
all right here so this is a current to
typical workflow of a menu process of
mass spec I see also two here actually
LC and massive is actually not the
limiting step and now I'll show you why
when we have the sample coming in that's
the only important I can find I'll just
use this one it takes about a few hours
or even overnight from the sample to get
here and then we through the sample
receiving side or 10 or 30 C 30 minutes
alright
and then go through sample preparation
it's another focus on the time we're
talking about 10 or 30 this is also
manual process and then after the sample
is a processed we can go down to the
math back LLC separation is few minutes
as we see we typically put it on the
autosampler
and then go directly to mass spec mass
spec is we're talking like a
milliseconds analysis for each analyte
it's also pretty fast so you can see I
label them into a different color even
so far we know this is actually the most
least manual process in the whole
pipeline right but after that we'll also
need more time like data review takes
more time and then data reporting if you
don't have an interface that will be
more time as well
so although the current of workflow the
focus is really for sample prep and
before and after LCM aspects that
introduce a lot of the labor-intensive
functions this is just an example that
we have this testing vitamin D what that
means for data review and data reporting
let's see estimated we actually have
about 300 to 400 samples a day we report
to d2 and d3 that's about 600 results
each one we interview with the five
digits we're talking about 3000 digits
per day and every one of those need to
be checked by another step so this takes
a lot of time so this one is probably to
work with dr. Allen Rockwood and which
is actually published this a couple
years ago so this is the current of
workflow so we also propose a couple
models just you know just for the fun on
that so even we're talk about automation
what can we imagine I think this is
really not rocket science that just
something for people to do really it's a
pretty intuitive one model we caught a
standalone model what their needs is
like we have the sample receiving site
from barcode all packing one analyser
and sample prep handling liquid handler
and also data review that data reporting
and I put a by the National interface
separate as this is a extra very
important element to be to make this
more automated than what we have now
it's it just interface to receiver a lot
of time it's more like if you think
about this no preaching for any vendor
this is one of the Roche analyzers it's
just like a standalone coal bus this is
what we use so that's whatever for me
there with another model they'll cut an
integrated model is what about you we
can separate the pre-analytical part as
sample receiving sample preparation or a
low quality upfront or in one pipe one
and then after that we put on a
different stations one the sample if we
need to chemistry we do chemistry line
if we need to do hematology we'll put
our mythology and you know athletes in
maybe mass spec can be one of that so
there will be a really interesting model
to think about and that will certainly
help our system quite a bit and this is
also a massive and very impressive
pipeline that we can actually find from
our line so this is the basically the
line here we go to different stations or
we can you know use the line let me see
here or this way or one of them is mass
spec those are all I think interesting
ideas to think about so they're
certainly going to solve some of the
challenges that we have with automation
I know we have some are they automated
you know something like this or more of
the standalone on the market and now I'm
not going to go to the the deep
conversation on that but I think if
we're really making very big strikes in
this area all right the next few minutes
actually I wanted to touch base about
the training because this is a very very
important field now we all know it's
very challenging everybody have trouble
getting medical technology to run
particularly from a spec so this is a
really a bottleneck beyond everything
else this is a bottleneck for us to
moving forward and we think about the
future of mass spec this is the area
that we have to think about it have to
discuss I also spend quite a bit time
the last few year to really build a
community and to share some of the
knowledge --is alright okay so what are
we talking about when we really think
about the staff level to run a mass spec
lab so this is the I call that ideal
structure we have a couple people we
call them experts here
sitting on top and to help you for
development develop many of your I see
and then we have another layer people
they can do troubleshooting we know that
we need people doing troubleshooting and
we have a great you know of people that
here covering as the operations this is
the ideal I mean everybody I think that
I'll be very happy we have have this
this I call it the real life structure
this is we see the holes here here this
this that and will actually we're happy
if you have even one person can expert
at that level to help with the
development but not necessarily true for
everybody and the same is true for
troubleshooting maybe you have two
people music you want to have you know
two more people you said it one more so
those are all real challenges in the lab
so the reason being for that is that
well we know it's hard to find people
hard to train hard to even to get people
to get to the level that we want all
right so yeah here is your very limited
training at school from a spec all right
but if you are lucky to help somebody
what are kind of the functions that we
need to think about it a different level
this is what I listed a few things for
personnel when they do troubleshooting
right first of all they need to be able
to follow the protocols for validation
they need to troubleshoot concerns like
you know the pressure is up the pressure
is low right the calm get clogged all
that they need to know the basic routine
concerned another is identify concerns
with you identify basically before that
happened was you know do you have other
approaches to identify concert with our
different athletes even be able to
another as separate HPLC issues versus
mass spec issues and also the facility
24 other staffs and even general create
SOPs and procedures I all can see you
know those are the people who need to
know as a personnel for troubleshooting
also particularly be able to separate
HPLC issues for some aspect business
huge the person need to have a lot
experience with an instrument and be
able to troubleshoot and also back here
HPLC background is very very helpful
majority of the issues are coming from
HPLC rather than mass spec
how about experts the expert level need
to know how to do method development
validation
how to know bring asses in house and
they need to know you develop a new
asses in-house also training other
people in the lab all Iran busy lab to
develop a test and also you know set up
protocols how to have people avoid the
common issues on all of that our candor
the expert arena
and also that you know the candidate
requires a lot experience a lot of
attention to detail and need to be
creative so those are actually very
healthy not really easy to find I said
this before and some people like it so
I'm gonna repeat it this is I called it
the ten years experience is not equal to
one year experience repeated at ten
times what that means is that to become
the expert every day every time we're
doing experiment we have with the goal
to get better just like people playing
golf and so you just hit the ball every
day right you won't go anywhere but if
you wanted to be good every stroke with
a goal to get better so that's is a 10
years experience every day you get more
you learn more we do have a lot of great
people actually who are at that level
but also they know and we know that's
not easy to achieve that this is another
challenge for mass spec with that
actually even people doing like other as
they develop for research they also come
here not as knowing instrument doesn't
necessarily mean they know how to
develop a clinical assay there's a whole
set of anology that people need to know
related to the clinical asses of
clinical operations and a clinical grade
of as it developed its
it's different from a research asset all
right so the question is where to gain
those experience right there's first of
all there's no shortcut for hands-on
experience so I put a hands-on right in
the middle and you can also get this
from colleagues conference and vendors
and online trainings so I want to take
this opportunity to share a couple of
things actually that that I've been
going to that gain a lot experience from
wine you know like the online training
vendors have that we also have the
online certificate program and also
journals that I see : will come true now
we also have the Journal of applied lab
for medicine gave a lottery infant
information they're also the
conference's and a community in UCC is
great I'm a member of you know the
division was set up for the goal to
actually educated people and help people
to know one to learn more of Matt's back
and a SMS that's another area and also
MS SEO as people here some people know
and have made a lot of contributions the
ruling industry area those are all the
meetings in the conference's that I
would recommend people to go here are
actually just a couple of things I'm not
part of that I just wanted to share with
people the area let one is the people
need to think about what we need to do
when we talk about the training to is
hopefully this going to be a helpful
tool that you can use we have like two
years ago set up an online certificate
program wanted to introduction another
troubleshooting for the introductory
where to started with how even to make a
reagent so people are the training led
to do mass spec we need to actually talk
about how you into may make a reagent
how use a skill how to renew running
online make curves water HPLC me how the
mass spec work how to integrate Peaks
and sample extraction
separation preparation processes and the
dollars and people all of that we
including the introduction course and
with the personnel here on the right
corner to show all the experts that
shared that experience will have the
troubleshooting which Carver how to do
system suitability sample prep HPLC
troubleshooting
spec you a QC calibration their review
even a lot those are more specific
things that we or you to think about
Mort we need to have those are the area
to think about now see how to take this
court or this is the areas for you to
think about and also you know with
online learning this is area I think
it's very important we opened up for
people to talk about you know go to the
labs with the mass spec workshops would
half-day we've been doing the last
couple years that I'm product new part
of that I'm working with the different
institutions to even show the same a
real mass spec lab what they do how they
set that up
we got question like hey what's the
nitrogen generator
alright worth the tank what do you mean
you need an emergency power supply so
all of those provide opportunities for
people to gain more knowledge I also
wanted to appreciate the organizations
that has been very supportive that I
also use this as a lust rating that we
do have a very very generous community
to support everybody if you need a
question you would find people on
alright so with that I think I used this
as a slide to summarize what we've
talked about one is that mass spec has
played an important role in clinical
Diagnostics I think it will continue to
play a make a very big difference in
healthcare to areas on one specific to
point out automation and education of
big challenges in the further employment
Asia mess they in clinical labs we also
have very exciting it should be
next-generation clinical mass spec will
cover various new applications actually
this is the last light I want to leave
with everybody when we ask questions so
that to really figure I'm very visual
person so this is the things I think
about this is what we have so far and
this is the some already there and
occurring more application microbiology
is coming e more applicants going to
come out from Petra and protein
we prefer next further along informatics
we're talking about automation we're
talking about there's already in models
that on the market and then teaching
image you will talk about precision
medicine miniaturization and disruptive
technology all of that education
training is the bottleneck that we
cannot ignore all right so I'll and my
presentation here while welcome many
questions thank you so much dr. John for
that informative presentation and now
how to use numbers we will start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and click the send button II
will answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's take a look at our
audience questions that are already
coming in dr. John our first question
from our audience is what will happen
with anatomic pathology will mass spec
take over the whole world
well I think that's a excellent question
yeah I would like to see vests Beck
would take over the whole world I'm
passionate about but also I think
everything has its own place certainly
you know mass spec and a play continue
play a very big role e overall in terms
of anatomic pathology or we could know
here particularly the tissue imaging
I think mass spec in the near future
will make a huge difference in that area
will that come next year I'm not sure
would that be like a 20 years down the
road I think that's perfect - for I
think even your future we'll see huge
differences but on the other hand this
does not many anatomic thought it won't
exist or pathologist won't have anything
to do I think we have so many things
that we can do as a platform as a tool
for mass spec will provide I think a lot
of data for that so that people can free
that do more
other things so that you can have the
things that can be routine it can be
automated can be processed by the
instrument and them to give that form
aspect to take over and then our
pathology can do other you know more
innovative or or interesting other tasks
that instrument or technology cannot do
wonderful thank you being our next
question is you have spearheaded the
mass spec division with a htc can you
tell us a little more about the division
and activities that people can benefit
yeah first of all I wanted you know this
is has the obtained effort a group
effort to get this off ground there were
many people involved I'm extremely
honored to be part of that and working
with many people we being as a division
for three years within a CC and a lot of
activities involved with that I think
the overall plan is to set up a platform
or home for clinical mass spec within a
sec so that people come in from
different areas like academic hospitals
community hospitals industry regulatory
bodies will be working with new FDA's in
government to have a same platform on
the same room on the same table discuss
the same topic is that we all care about
which is the clinical mass spec and we
have a lot of activities involved with
that for our members like we have the
annual conference last couple years at
the in Chicago and this year just
finishing October in Philadelphia we're
going to continue to have that with a
day-and-a-half conference provide
cutting-edge and also practical
informations and like workshop for
instance we I just got described a
little bit which provided a lot of value
for our members the online course I
think the third one obviously you have
to basically take a read you know and
then would see and do the do part of me
and a few others have been working on on
like a few days on-site training course
from a spec with medical technology and
even residents we are the universe
Rochester is working with our medical
technologists training and people with a
CDC and amory a few very good colleagues
that work on and I know Polly from Wake
Forest are doing on that too and there's
a lot of activities with pain ACC any
meeting will be participating with FDA
regulatory on LD T's I think really a
lot of things going on they also have so
far over 400 members that hope wherever
interested become of that and any
questions suggestions we'll be happy to
listen and the goal is to help the
community and grow bigger and benefit
our members wonderful thank you dr. John
and thank you our audience members today
we have a really active participation
can you share more with us about the
challenges in training and education and
what do you see the community what can
they be doing and and to help as a whole
yeah yeah there's highlighted here this
is this is a question although I already
discussed quite a few of this I think
there's a topic that we need these
awareness of the whole community I think
the challenge here in addition to what I
mentioned one is the lack of education
in medical technology training program
so we cannot hire somebody out of
medical technology or even with bachelor
degrees and just to rhom aspect so
that's a gap with the whole community I
think we if you know somebody if you are
part of the program please consider to
add math back and even like two courses
three courses like half a day to your
curriculum for people to start familiar
with the technology so I think that just
a little bit information goes a long way
so there for people to be more prepared
and more ready to do that - is that even
the basic technologies I mean now the
one thing automation is a fantastic it's
a beautiful thing but it also limited
our hands-on training with the mass spec
there's a lot of training a lot of
hands-on piece as we see with an online
training program we start teacher how to
people prepared with our own training -
anyhow with teach people how to prepare
how to measure and reagents so many
things are automated our agents ready
those skills start to lose I think
that's also important for to keep in
mind that we need to keep that going so
you know with the whole community I
think we just need to raise the
awareness of this technology of this
platform and provide opportunities if
you are lab doing mass spec open your
doors somebody wanted to see go there
take a look so I think all of the things
community camp can really help make a
difference
wonderful we have time for one more
question from our audience and here's a
related question there are new models of
mass spec on the market with the
intention to have them automated do you
think that you will solve the automation
problem for mass spec in the near future
good yeah very good question it's very
exciting to see
just for a comple I'm now going to name
the names for the vendor I think people
ask the question they already know we
see the models actually launched ACC
this year of the automated that kind of
yet automated platform or like
understand alone model that I discussed
which is very exciting to see I think
you know we are really moving to the
right direction with the automation but
is that perfect over there yet I I don't
think so I think there's still a lot of
work to do because by the end of the day
how do we prepare the samples how do we
have a kid to be ready how did their
people are trained to do that and on top
of that is the troubleshooting with
you're talking about HPLC what you're
talking about mass spec those are all
the things that we need to think about
and pay attention it's not like we put
in two pieces together in a bog so then
we can call that automated process
there's a lot more into that I think
that banders everybody have been doing a
lot of work this is a huge huge step
forward in our community to have the
model ready for us to evaluate and look
at yeah I think we're really on the
right path I can see you know in the
near future that more and more
applications with automated platform in
the clinical community particularly for
those that wanted to have that and
without the expertise and the staff to
support that yeah I'm very optimistic
wonderful thank you so much dr. Jon for
your presentation did you want to
provide any final comments for the
audience
yeah first of all thanks to the audience
those are great questions and I'm the
key questions I just wanted to leave as
one note as this is the area that we're
all passionate about and for P we're
actually listening and it takes it takes
a whole village it it takes a whole team
to move us to the next stage clinical
mass spec I call it a huge a big
platform it's not just an instrument I
think it's a platform we can put a lot
of things and add a lot of applications
onto that I'm just very excited to be in
this field I think for people who are
thinking about it please think more
about it because this is the area
they're going to grow very fast and just
you start incorporating your thoughts
and your plans how we can use that more
effectively in our community and to
benefit our society and I'll see for the
betterment of the healthcare so I'm I'm
very excited to continue to work in this
field thank you so much dr. John thank
you for your presentation and also thank
you for your important research I'd also
like to thank lab roots and also Agilent
Technologies for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April of 2018
so receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us
we hope to see you again soon device